here's a beacon what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back here on
Rob here's a question for you do you
have plans to run for office
no god no jeez Louise no I'm too much of
a consensus guy I can't deal with the
the fringes of either the parties I'm
like a middle guy they don't like guys
like me anymore other than we would
middle guy in your party no no no really
I'm a conservative I mean but it depends
who you are it's all perspective now so
like I would think the fringe thinks
that I'm conservative but not quite
quite fringe like a modern Rockefeller
Republican no no I'm more conservative
I'm more blunt but but if if you want to
get things done I mean that's you want
to run for office but I'm sure look I
met a lot of Congress people I mean this
is a compliment I've never met you
before but and we probably don't agree
in a lot but I could tell in this hour
there's somebody home here yeah there's
not a try a lot of the Republican
Congressmen I've met of any congressman
on both sides there is absolutely no
intelligence test remember Congress is
representative of the American people we
get voted in by us absolutely right I
mean that the this fence McAllister guy
is the guy who took duck dynasty to the
State of the Union that was his big call
I got my I got my picture taken seat
duck dynasty at the state yeah it's the
biggest Facebook kid I've ever had
really yeah
do you think Congress could find Ukraine
on a map would it look much different
yes we could we at least know that yes
yes oh I don't know about that like it's
a lot of this wrong a Latvia Lithuania
Ukraine Belarus I can name them all - I
did I said Otis you Ukraine Georgia but
yeah man we we know the special bond
Armenia I just have a hard time of
Cossacks and kurtosis I think August and
Kyrgyz I have a real hard time with that
one that's what a knowledgeable panel
yes yes so the grader is Cuba with
society mr. Baugh was both government
would you take a picture with Assange if
you'd have this moment if you had a
chance to do it a picture with you
Julian no probably not no really yeah
and you know talk about Russia to
Snowden really hurt us what one reason
that they're able to do some of the
stuff they're there know what they know
about us militarily and otherwise
because the Snowden probably offloaded
everything and I mean that's that's the
most worrisome thing about Russia right
now
that truth truthfully so now I would not
get a picture with Julian Assange well
we don't know that I don't think I
really probably we don't know that for a
fact what exactly he offloaded and he
himself but I said that he but I do you
do because you have meetings that well
but I say probably right okay yeah
that's no did a lot of bad things and
let the run we will never know those
things cuz we're not we don't get the
briefings okay like we ought to tell the
American people what what Snowden let I
watch ensue yeah I think that would be
on would scare the hell out of us no he
sees us escape our alone to cut Romania
tennis to you squishy you know I think
it's much worse than the rush to
Parliament where he can discuss these
things point yeah right no that's why we
have such admiration for you cuz you're
going back into the Lions Den and you
you don't have to cuz I mean three
picture deal Rob Oh kidding you're
kidding me they could they imagine an
arc is my love interest you kidding me
do you think Jeb Bush will run in 2016
yes yeah I do too yeah yeah I hope so
because he's honest he just just showed
he's an honest guy weather well yeah he
did he did he did something that I mean
he's staking out a ground much like Rand
Paul was sticking out of ground that no
one else is staking out with foreign
policy he's staking out compassion he
owns that in the room
he said because he said immigrants who
come to this country from Mexico it's
not a felony it's an act of love they're
doing for their family I mean I could
just hear the boos if he said that at a
Republican debate last time so here's my
question it's if it's Hillary against
Jeb Bush so we have more than two
families that that can run for president
say the Hatfields and McCoys it never
ends
I mean it's not like people are being
forced to vote for them
you know yes I see you say the people
elect who they want we do have sort of a
democracy my grant names that's right
it's white it's white people your
budweiser yeah
Budweiser I used to be at the liquor
delivery boy but was it so like more
than every other beer combined did you
ever hear anybody ever say boy this
Budweiser is a great beer no but they
still drink it it was promoted your
names you know that mean everyone knows
this from voting I mean you don't submit
from running a campaign if you just get
your name out there people will vote for
you so people you Clinton I think it's
even worse than that I think we're
jealous of the British we have like a
royalty complex you know we we just we
just love the whole dynastic concept of
it and then it adds that sort of like
reality show theme it's just really
twisted no we're on our way there in
terms of class like the rich stay rich
the poor stay poor the same family names
stay at the top I mean we are creating
our own looks like monarchy not a
monarchy that are gonna battle if people
are voting for it they literally are
creating it I mean it's it's not it's
not the bushes are the Clintons who are
doing it it's the people who vote for
them yeah well I would argue that there
are powerful forces that are better
sponsored we got to Hanna disease she's
gonna segment yeah oh don't don't want
to do it because I mean Mike Mike Rogers
great example he's getting out I mean
there's a lot of stuff he could do he's
had it with what the whole thing right
so would you have good people if you
think they're good people or not but
decent people who want to try to do good
things for the nation say I'm out that's
a bad place to be in this country right
and I think you have people like Bush
say I may be in let's let's see how
things go that's that's pretty cool but
it's a lot of that because it really
does suck so much to be a congressman I
mean you have to spend how many hours
lobsters and limousines is crazy it's
not okay it's most it's a lot of begging
for money no no it isn't so much that
it's flying back and forth is being gone
for my kids like a three frayed bunk
gone out of San Diego being back in that
hellhole in DC all the time that's not
very fun but if you can pick things that
you like and you could focus on those
and try to do a few good things at the
same time chase the shiny object around
because whatever's big in the news
that's what we'll be dealing with the
next week right but you have things that
you you really believe in and you try to
get those things done and if you can do
that then you enjoy it because you can
get things
but if you want to change the world in
your first term or your 10th term you're
not you're not going to see that it's a
slow change one either way but you are a
supporter of [ __ ] right I'm a supporter
of punk rock and freedom all right well
what what's her can you ask yes please
done yes yes the covers Mona's average a
simple series memories Yoko
well it's an interesting opportunity to
talk directly with the politician you
see global in citizen but you mean way
too serious to me lady [ __ ] pocos you
kudos triple K Co Co Co Co is Ukraine
it's a stick on the least interesting
person here - I would ask robber bill a
question well you're the most powerful
it's it's interesting to ask why do
politicians never take up the
prison-themed until they run into big
problems like they've just ran into in
Ukraine well here's what I do it so a
90% legit city right until late will
make a revolution politicians are really
interested in the prison theme 90% of
American prisoners are in state and
local prisons is that right roughly yeah
roughly 10 to 10 percent are in
federally 14 percent actually yeah all
right 14 percent so we don't I mean
besides the federal mandatory drug
minimums and some other federal but I
would say those are the only ones are
going to change because there are there
are federal minimums that is more of a
state issue and you have Texas actually
reformed their entire prison system in
2000 or something so there was more
rehabilitation and less incarceration
yeah well I think it goes beyond that
the prisoners just don't have a lobby
they know that there's roosters there's
nobody advocating for prisoners and and
there they don't they have no political
power whatsoever there's why people
change
it's expensive and it's the market is
making a change of texture what's right
answer to have prisoners right right
Rick Perry's actually turned into this
really unlikely advocate not just for
drug law reform but also for reform of
prisons like the way that you treat
prisoners which is something we didn't
really talk about when they I'm Rand
Paul believes it you know ex-felon
should be able to vote yeah and we've
spanning the discussion beyond just drug
the drug war which is important because
it is a whole culture of prisons and a
whole culture of putting people in
prison that we need to change it's not
just like oh we'll just you know my son
will not get arrested for
hot on him you know for too long I think
we've been using prisons as a way to
just deal with our poverty problem it's
just it's our way of sweeping it under
the rug right you know the the biggest
problem Americans just don't want to
think about poverty they don't want they
don't want to think about their role in
it whether they're that they have any
you know guilt or a liability toward it
and so they'd much rather have everybody
behind a wall somewhere and not have to
look at it and I think and that's one of
the reasons why I don't think this
problems gonna change how do you say
goodnight in Russian what nice children
no Qi or even asking thank you very much
Real Time with Bill Maher ask Bill and
his guests your questions right after
the show at hbo.com or on Twitter